well if i wasn't awake enough to realize
i had issues to work on that's the rest
of this world
then you're asleep that's most people
and you will repeat your patterns
most people most people most people
are living more people are waking up
right now there's a lot of awakening
happening but i would say the majority
are living in a place where they're just
living trigger to trigger and
anesthetizing through the drug
the food the alcohol whatever it is to
just push it down push it down push it
down push it down
but anybody that's watching this right
now they're not because they have the
willingness to see things differently
they would not be landing on this
video or audio right now if they were
not
open and willing i believe that each and
every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and i
want to help give you the tools to make
that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is gabby bernstein she
is an author
on self-improvement through spirituality
is the way i describe it i remember
seeing gabby
in vermont at a wonderlust which is a
big like yoga festival
and the things that she said that day i
still remember today and it was years
ago
uh her newest book out is called super
attractor
and so we talked about what that looks
like we talked about
some of her struggles in her life that
have forced her to look within
um and also you know of course the signs
of of what to look for when you know
you're on the right track
and how to get on the more um in tune
life flow or the spiritual path or you
know just
just flowing with the universe and that
if you can just kind of
allow the universe will bring you
everything that you could ever want and
more so
you love wayne dyer and abraham hicks
right yes ma'am
gosh they are my favorite yep how long
ago did you like who did you discover
first
i i think wayne has has been i say has
been even though he's deceased but
he has been a mentor and teacher and
guide of mine even before he was my
friend even before he was in my life
physically right so
i've had the privilege of of of feeling
that presence and that guidance and i
also still today
feel the presence of wayne probably even
greater now
even though he's not in the physical
form uh
abraham hicks have been a huge through
line throughout the work that i've been
inspired to teach
in this book i mentioned them 26 times
really yes
i would have dedicated the book to
abraham if it wasn't for my son that was
born
other than that which is you know a huge
thing dedicated to my son
yeah abraham has um really helped me
with philosophies of like the
understanding of energy
and momentum and what what if you had to
identify like your biggest takeaway from
wayne and from abraham what would they
be i guess you know it's a wayne dyer
quote change the way you look at things
and the things you look at change
and that belief system is the through
line through super attractor it's really
about
having the willingness and the
commitment
to be in a constant state of
allowing yourself to see things
differently how does allowing see that's
a that's a hard thing what do you like
go deeper into allowing to see things
differently what is that so i believe
it's a choice
that we make it's not it's not okay i'm
just gonna practice this and practice
this and then one day it'll just
stick that can happen but i believe it's
a conscious day-to-day moment
moment-to-moment choice to choose again
to see things in a different perspective
so when we make that commitment and that
choice
is actually a surrender it's a surrender
it's a state of allowing because
we're really saying i'm going to give
over all of my
stories and belief systems and agenda
and needs and all the beliefs that we
think that we have to create around
ourselves to feel good enough
i'm gonna put all of that aside choose
again
and allow a new perspective to come
through so
it it can't be another chore it has to
be something that we give over
when we when i say it i mean personal
growth
seeing things through the different lens
it has to be a conscious
moment-to-moment choice
and a lot of surrender is required
i'm so glad you said surrender because
it
that so i i saw you speak
at in vermont at wonderlust back in the
summer of 2016.
i was on a girls trip and uh where
we we loved yoga and you know it was
great to hear the talks and so my friend
stacy who um has kind of been our little
spiritual guide in the group she's
always one step ahead
she's always just always one step ahead
of me where i'm kind of like and what
about that concept again let's talk
about that yeah cool
um and she was like gabby's amazing we
should go listen to her
and so i remember i took a ton of notes
but the
but the thing that really stuck of
course which is a big point in the book
was
surrender and then surrender some more
yeah
so you went into a long
story about wanting to have a baby yeah
and how it wasn't happening for you and
you had to surrender
and then you also mentioned timelines
and how you get so attached to a
timeline and now i'm starting to
paraphrase a little bit more because
again
you're four years ago you're 100 right
and it's so
and ever since then timelines has always
been something that i've talked about
when i talk about
if you can just let go of timelines
because of what you said that day
vermont and so it was really powerful
yeah so
um but i i would just love to hear about
that process a little bit more in depth
instead of the sort of like
here's 300 people listening to you speak
out wonderless but
i mean you it was it was all about
wanting something so badly
yes and which is always interesting too
again in the abraham hicks stuff which
is all about like the resistance that it
creates with the uh anyway
but so you wanted a baby and it wasn't
happening
so oh i actually it's such a through
line throughout the book as well i feel
like my son is just like
weaving this whole book together uh
the the secret to truly manifesting your
desires is to give over your timeline
and to really recognize that your plan
may not be the best plan so
it's fine to hold a desire and to be
clear about what you want
and to put energy into what you desire
and to celebrate that desire and to
bring
bring positive energy into your life
every single day that's going to lead
you closer to that desire
but when you get into the story of i
need this now to feel
good enough or i need it to happen now
because it's convenient in my life or
anything that's
an agenda beyond the surrendered state
of
allowing that's when we get in the way
of the actual manifestation
because we're always we're all the
universe is always delivering
always delivering but just not always
when we think we need it and often not
always in the exact same form that we
think we need it
so when i write about methods for
manifesting a life beyond your wildest
dreams so much of what i write about in
this book is how to surrender
and how to turn it over and how to
release it and how to trust the universe
there's a story i tell in the book about
how i tried to conceive my son for three
years you heard you were you heard the
earlier side of the story which was
here i am i'm trying to conceive it's
you probably saw me crying on the stage
this is so difficult for me i think we
were crying
we were all crying because i felt that
struggle and i felt that comparison
and then you know three years later
towards the end of that journey
i really got to that state of surrender
and i started to really let
the universe show up for me and so this
is this is i'll tell the story from the
book because it's such a good one
this is such a good one and one of my
favorite places to manifest is
driving so i'm i love driving because
it's like driving around
the country there's no one around and
all you see is foliage
at this this moment that i'm going to
refer to was in the fall so there was
like epic foliage all around
me i was just listening to mantra music
driving
feeling so lit up so excited i just kept
thinking about
how wonderful it was to live in the
country and how excited i was to have
all this the support in my life and
these friends in my life and
and just really getting into the good
vibrations like just feeling good
feeling good
reaching for more reaching for more and
just listening to the mantras and
chanting the mantras
when out of nowhere i felt this presence
of a baby in the back seat
it felt like a baby in a car seat behind
me
and i started crying cause it felt so
real to me i felt i felt so real that i
started
being deeply moved by that experience
and then
i heard this inner voice say to me this
voice of your intuition
inspiration loud and clear your baby's
coming in march
and it was so loud and authoritative i
know it's just like
in my face i was like okay march march
here comes the baby in march the baby's
coming on march
and so i started you know really getting
heady about like oh the baby's coming
march and i started getting back on the
timeline
and so the second i saw that happen i
just said okay universe you take this
that doesn't work show me a sign that
this baby's coming in march and i want
the sign to be lily's
i just chose that sign a week later i
get a letter in the mail
from a reader and in the letter was a
little prayer card and on the back of
the prayer card was a picture of
archangel gabriel who was typically
depicted holding lilies
so on the back of the card that he sent
me he said i don't know why but i felt
that you needed this
i was like yes i did i got my card i
marked my baby's coming in march
then early march rolls around and i
wasn't pregnant
and so i was devastated because here i
was i was like the universe doesn't have
my back what's going on
and i walked into my husband's office i
was hysterically crying i'm like when is
this gonna happen i really thought it
was coming i thought it was now what's
happening
and we just sat there and he held me and
all of a sudden the
phone that was sitting on the desk my
phone
started playing a song all of a sudden
out of
nowhere and you know when you think like
all my phone's doing something weird too
like go to turn it off
but it i looked at the phone and as i
went to try to turn it off i heard the
lyrics of the song and the lyrics were
way go lily wiggle lilly wiggle lily
then i look closer and the album title
the song is called way go lily repeating
the word lily over and over again and
the album title is i see the sign
can't make it up can't i get up these
guys are laughing
wow so that so that happened and
uh i just rejoiced because i was like
okay the universe is fully
behind me this is definitely happening
even if it's not on my time i'm gonna
give it over maybe it's not march i'll
give it over thank you universe
and then i got pregnant in april and i
did the
math i conceived march the end of march
the last day of march
unbelievable yeah so that kind of
synchronicity that kind of support that
kind of reminders
the recognition the guidance the
intuition that happens when we get into
a good feeling vibration like i was in
the car
when we allow ourselves to just feel
good no matter what
and this book isn't a book on how to get
things though i says that on the cover
you know manifest life beyond your
wildest dreams
it's a book on how to feel good and when
we feel good
whatever we desire starts to come into
our life in a form that we could never
imagine
and uh i can stand behind it i can stand
behind it because i've lived every
practice in that book
even in my darkest moments when you need
it most
what if some of those other dark moments
like
what have they been most recently i'm
about six months
uh in recovery from postpartum
depression anxiety and insomnia
um i was and and i was
at the lowest point suicidal and i was
about four months into my record my my
postpartum
and that's when it came on which is not
typical usually it comes on earlier
uh i was at the darkest moment of my
life and i've been through a lot of dark
moments you know i've
been in sober recovery for 14 years i've
remembered trauma
but like this scenario was by far rocked
me to my core
brought me to my knees but i
stayed in constant contact with a higher
power of my own understanding i stayed
in constant communication with that
inner guidance system through prayer
and even though the prayers weren't
making it go away the prayers were
guiding me to the doctors
the the medication the healers whatever
it was that i needed
to get back to baseline and
i'm feeling really good now because i've
had the ability to
get myself back to a really stable place
and then
do the deepest personal growth work i've
ever done
so i can see that very very dark period
of my life as
a catalyst for tremendous change and
for this incredible opportunity to be on
podcasts like this
and you know national television and
wherever i can get my voice out and talk
about postpartum and talk about how
serious a mental of a mental health
condition
it is and how mandatory it is that we
allow ourselves to be helped what made
this the darkest
because as you've said there have been
lots of challenging things and
and now you seemingly have everything
right you you
you wanted a child for so long and you
have it and and what made this
the darkest i i listen i've had i've had
many moments
where i think it i think it was
a culmination of years of personal
growth and
and all that i had behind me that
allowed me to get out of that point but
the reason that it was the
darkest moment was because it was my
my first taste of really understanding
what mental illness is
wow i've while i've been in sober
recovery for a long time and i struggled
with addiction when i was in my 20s and
remembered you know dissociated traumas
and
those scenarios in my life were probably
considered mental illness from the
standpoint of being depressed or having
you know having to to anesthetize
through drugs or alcohol
but i'd never experienced the type of
mental illness that was causing panic
attacks
that was causing insomnia that was
causing me to say on mother's day i want
to kill myself
and here i was i authored seven
self-help books and
i was suicidal uh so i'm
so deeply grateful for that dark bottom
because
now i can speak to mental illness with
so much conviction
and authority and and most importantly
authenticity
and i can see how when people come to me
my audiences and for years they'd say i
i'm depressed or i have this uh you know
biochemical issue
and my response was probably part of the
stigma i would say things like
well you know just meditate more and but
without the
level of awareness of where these kinds
of conditions can take you
i wasn't in a position to be able to
speak to medication and how you could
use medication to go deeper on your
spiritual path if you needed to and
to really honor that side of the
conversation
and so it's been it's been wildly
valuable for me and for anyone that's
been hearing me speak about this because
i've been getting countless
emails from people saying thank you for
describing my symptoms and helping me
see that i needed to get more help
what does that more help look like you
talked about medications
is this traditional medications or um in
my case i
i was guided to a psychiatrist my
therapist intervened
and said she has she has a biochemical
issue she has has to be
medicated this is not her her tools are
no longer working was her
and um so i went on zoloft which is
actually the
most commonly prescribed medication for
pregnant women and for postpartum
uh because it's the medication that you
can breastfeed on and it's
uh it has the most uh stats on how it is
for pregnancy um so i was still
breastfeeding at the time so i went on
zoloft
and it took several months to get to the
right therapeutic dose and
and once i was i i felt safe again
and that safety has allowed me to do
even deeper work which is
i've been doing emdr therapy what is
that
emdr therapy is eye movement
desensitization and reprocessing
and it's to sort of simplify it you have
different buzzers in your hands while
you're in your ears while you're talking
about the emotional disturbance
and what happens is it it allows
the energetic disturbance to to be
handled in a different part of the brain
so it's typically locked in
in in this little you know let's put it
like i'm not a neuroscientist
but let's talk about it this way it's
locked up right the trauma's locked up
i'm not either so it's okay
and you know if you dissociate from a
trauma it's on lockdown but your body
still remembers
you get triggered all the time you you
just you know you become
you can become an addict you can become
a workaholic you can do all the things
to avoid the feelings of those triggers
but when you start to practice something
like emdr therapy it starts to
open up the brain to start to like my
therapist said it in this way where it
opens up the resourced part of your
brain
that can help you uh almost
work out the traumatic experience in
that moment the trip the trauma that got
locked up in the first place right so it
allows it to be
be i'm saying this in so many strange
ways but trying to simplify it
so it it it helps you release the uh
the the trauma in such a way that you
can actually walk out of an emdr session
one session even and feel completely
different
so do you have to recognize the trauma
not even you don't even have to remember
anything you can just talk about
the way it physically feels or you could
talk about how you yelled at the doorman
today
and that experience of yelling at the
doorman might have been
your trauma response and so if you just
go into the feeling of that trauma
response it can unlock the
the fight or flight that's an area that
i've been diving into myself
which is childhood trauma attachment
trauma yeah
and everyone has it yeah everybody
yeah yeah you're able to identify
something in that yeah i so in 2016
i remembered being abused as a child
and i remembered it through a dream
first
and then i was like no thank you i'm not
gonna touch that
because it's terrifying that was just a
bad dream that was no but it was a real
dream like
you know when you wake up i woke up and
i was like that was the most real dream
i've ever had
then i uh wound up a days later just
down the street from here
in my therapist office and she said
something that triggered me to accept
that it was true and that put me on a
really deep journey of big big
growth and recovery and in that time of
that growth and recovery i wrote three
books you know i wrote books that were
deep
and books that that were healing me as i
wrote them
do you know where it was holding you
back because
everywhere everywhere yeah i mean in
some ways it was a great gift because it
gave me this deep core desire to
to to serve people and to help people
feel better because i was
constantly in a state of fight or flight
and i was using my
spiritual practice every single day to
get back to baseline get back to
baseline
but i was just like this i was like so
far out and then i'd come so far back in
and then i'd have some days of
sustainable serenity and then it'd go so
far back out
because the trauma was still in my body
it was still in my
it was in my brain it was just it was it
was deleting me
by the time i was in 2016 i was becoming
safe enough to remember it because i'd
done so much great spiritual and
personal
growth work that i was getting to a
place where i was safe enough but it was
affecting me mainly with um
addiction addictive patterns the uh work
addiction first of all
drug addiction and um and alcoholism and
then it was
and then it was work addiction and the
belief that that i am unsupported and
nobody can help me
not letting anybody help me so that was
your your
coping mechanism for just to create it
was to control yeah controlling is a big
coping mechanism
for trauma yeah i've dove into
like you know certain triggers i have
but i wouldn't say that everything was
affected but
you know identifying like where my where
are my weaknesses or where i repeat
patterns absolutely um are and then
where is the what is the feeling now
well the feeling is this like
oh i am not enough okay is that true of
course i'm i know i'm enough
right that's a conscious thought that's
not a subconscious thought
and so then you're doing um cbt
cognitive behavioral therapy like really
talking back to yourself
i do yes and i also do
um have you ever heard of elisa romeo
no she wrote a book called meet your
soul and
um and i read it and it and it has to do
with
you know uh understanding that your soul
is you are in direct communication
universe you're in direct communication
and so i do what i would call like soul
journaling yeah soul dialogue
beautiful where i'll it's so it has to
be
um not a lot of thought to it it has to
be very impulsive yeah so
um like my soul's name is lucy so i'm
like
okay like how am i doing today well
you're doing and then you just start
asking questions
because it was so a lot of that in super
attractor really yeah you ever done
anything like that
uh yes just stream of conscious writing
and and and
uh prompting so that you could let the
voice of your i would call your higher
self
come through i i also
uh have great faith in
that type of practice because so much of
of recovering from trauma is about
reintegration
and reintegrating with that child part
of yourself so
what happens is you know your adult self
becomes like the protector
but the child self is just the wounded
fear you know trend what that's who act
out with the trigger right
that's who's uh that's who's you know so
terrified in those moments
so we have to start to learn how to
reintegrate with
the bring the child self back to the
adult self on my 40th birthday this
really cool thing happened i was in a
yoga class and i was lying down in
shavasana this was last week so i just
turned 40.
and um just a week ago i was 39.
um
close to 30. so i um so i was lying in
shavasana after my yoga class and was
lying down and all of a sudden
i the the yoga teacher was like
searching for a song and i kept thinking
about stuff she's going to bring out a
song that's going to really do something
for me like i just knew it
and so she puts on some like 90s like
kind of emo song i don't even know what
it was it was like you know
so emo and it took me back to like
college and like feeling so lonely in
college in the snow
and driving around that i just felt that
feeling and then it took me to my drug
addiction and i saw myself on the floor
of my apartment and i was just
feeling that feeling and then it took me
to like my codependency and
relationships and i saw myself with my
now husband
but like the dark moments of that and
just being in those feelings and i just
saw myself in these in between periods
between you know
not in my child's self and not in my
full adult self but that
in between and i kept feeling myself
into these feelings and and
crying like on the you know on the mat
and shabbat not crying
and i just was like what a repair like i
came out of that and i was like that's
integration
like that's just that's that's a decade
over a decade of personal growth work
and spiritual work that just like
culminates in these moments
when we can go back and what i did was i
saw myself in these moments
and i went back and i grabbed that girl
of all those different
times and i brought her back to myself
and it's about bringing your
your younger self back to safety
that was awesome that's amazing
three and a half minutes of uh of such
therapy
um reintegration i mean that's something
that
you know it's one thing to think
something it's another thing to like put
it into practice that's right
and um and so what are some practices
like what are your normal ritualistic
practice
practices that keep you present because
life just gets to us
what keeps me present is transcendental
meditation
can you explain that yeah so i do two
20-minute meditations
every day there is a mantra that you're
given when you
get trained in tm you don't tell anybody
your mantra
uh and you repeat your mantra and repeat
munch or you close your eyes and relax
wherever you are even if you're in the
back of an uber or whatever you know
if you're busy you got to do where you
got to do it and you sit in your tm and
you repeat your mantra and then your
mind's going to wander
you're going to hear something you're
going to get taken out and you just
return to your mantra
then you'll get taken out again and
you'll turn to your mantra and then the
more you just allow the mantra to take
over the more you can go into that
transcendental state
where it's you release your thoughts and
your body
your cortisol levels drop and you just
you're just
really really supporting your nervous
system uh that is
my anchor that's that's been the most
valuable thing i've found
among many other things what are some
new things
uh the newest thing is playing with this
little boy called oliver
is a great spiritual practice for me uh
that's a big one
and what what do you mean great
spiritual practice well it's a practice
and
you know put that phone down be with the
person be with him completely i mean he
he's 11 months and he can see the second
i'm distracted
right and so it's just being in his full
presence and
and giving him my full presence out of
respect to his humanness
and to my ability and and
privilege of being a mother what's the
favorite what's the bet i'm not a mom
so i mean i'm in my i'm 37 i'm not a mom
i might be someday but getting up there
listen honey i have my first baby
i was 38 my pregnancy was 39 when i a
month later i delivered at 39.
i am going to be trying for my second
baby in my 40s okay
so you know take your time you're good
37 is okay
timelines exactly right exactly and more
and more women are having babies later
so
let that it's all good yeah it's okay
how i think one of the things that gets
complicated especially when you start
dipping into
childhood trauma and
triggers is it makes
relationships challenging very
because you might have a response to
something
it doesn't make sense right and they're
like what
i might be looking at him going what and
he look at me going why did you respond
like that
but it's a trigger and so what are
like how did that show up in your
relationship
i think that all relationships are
people coming together
where their wounds meet another person's
wounds so that they can be healed
and often if you show up for that right
and you say okay my wounds are
matching your wounds and we think that
together these wounds will become whole
because we're together but then it you
know all explodes
if we work on that then we can get to
that that place of real
holy love right that place of of
recognition and
and transformation but if we're not
gonna willing to do the work
then it won't work right or if one
person's willing to do the work and the
other person's not it won't match up
right so in my case my husband and i
have been both very committed to doing
our own work privately our work together
on spiritual path and personal growth
path and our commitment to
the work is what has given us
trans great transformation there's more
we're continuing to do it every single
day
but it gets better and better every day
the more
safe we become with each other the more
committed we become to our own personal
journey into each other
so i guess the answer is if if there's a
couple struggling with their wounds
you know triggering each other's wounds
which is most couples
get into couple therapy get somebody
great to support you if you can't afford
that
there are trainings out there there are
there are free courses online do
whatever you get books get a book
do the work do the work yeah
yeah it is work and i mean i'm reading a
book
called mindset by carol dweck and i had
this opinion of relationships that like
oh you love me or you don't
always are not all in yeah and i'm
reading the part about relation
yeah and you're reading the part about
open like growth mindset versus fixed
mindset
and i've obviously grown up and been
programmed
to be in a fixed mindset of like and you
know that's it's true because
i'm again these are the things that are
coming back to me but you know when i
was a kid my dad would be like oh
we suck we should just go home well
that's a fixed mindset right
the mindset needed to be okay we're not
very good we need to practice more
yeah right the attachment to like being
more connected with the progress versus
the results
totally um but it really it's
it's it's a real challenge and like you
said i it
takes two people that want to work on it
yeah that's that's it's required
be conscious to it yeah it's required
that you both do the work
yeah one person can't do it one person
can do their own work if their partner
is not willing to do the work
then you the other partner do the work
right not you but the person listening
do the do your work and there's always
the potential that in the presence of
your growth
they will rise up and say hey what are
you doing i'll do more of that whatever
it may be
there's also the high potential that
you'll just rise up and they won't
you're being i'm out
you know so just do your own work if
they're not willing to do it
you start by doing your own i do have a
theory i don't like that we're calling
it work though i want to call it
it's a privilege to do personal growth
work so i'd prefer to call it
a path right let's say like
get on your path i can't imagine not
being awake enough to realize
i need to work on it i can't imagine
not being awake enough to realize well
if i wasn't awake enough to realize i
had issues to work on that's the rest of
this world
then you're asleep that's most people
and you will repeat your patterns
most people most people most people
are living more and more people are
waking up right now there's a lot of
awakening happening
but i would say the majority are living
in a place where they're just
living trigger to trigger and
anesthetizing through the drug the food
the alcohol
whatever it is just push it down push it
down push it down push it down
but anybody that's watching this right
now they're not because they have the
willingness to see things differently
they would not be landing on this
video or audio right now if they were
not
open and willing what is your in the
vein of relationships i feel like when
you start getting into more of the
spiritual
side of life and perspectives you always
get that twin flame that comes up you're
like i want to find my twin flame do you
believe in that
do you believe that's true your perfect
twin flame is the person that triggers
all your [ __ ]
what about a dark night of the soul um
i think that we can have multiple
moments in our life that you could refer
to as a dark knight of the soul
but call it that call it a bottom call
it a transformation
call it the shift but when we have
moments in our life where we
are brave enough to go to the places
that scare us
that's when we come out the other side
and
it's it's our willingness and bravery to
go there that's going to be the way that
we heal
what was the first thing that you
remember
being like this is the one like i'm
i'm feeling brave enough to face this
fear the trauma
yeah when was that it's still happening
i'm still going i'm still working on it
oh yeah we're all in trauma but how long
ago was that
in 2016 i remembered um when i say
remembered you know we just so as a
child particularly you can dissociate
from the
experience and it gets locked up in the
brain like we talked about and
helping a coping mechanism to forget the
brain is an exceptional thing i mean
it's it's a protection mechanism
it says you know we can't we don't have
the the same trauma response like an
animal would have you know they could
just shake it out and move on
we don't shake it out so we hold it and
that's
fight flight or freeze right
so you you can be frozen then you can
act out in fight or flight when you're
triggered
uh and you can go back to frozen you
know it's a lot of different responses
so uh yeah i'm still working on it but
i'm feeling more free than i've ever
felt
i'm grateful for the dark nights because
they got me here
my girlfriends and i talk about the
spiritual journey and we talk about how
if you were to describe
the spiritual journey to someone no one
would sign up
right no one would sign up for the
spiritual journey on purpose
because it is challenging yes and it
hurts
because you're you're you're being an
alchemist to your traumas
and to your fears and the things going
on in your life and you're having to
face them to transform that's right
but once you've started the process you
never
you i i don't haven't met anyone that
will not continue the process and
doesn't in fact dive deeper
yes yes i i
agree i think some people though like i
would say for myself though if i had
two choice i did i had two choices i
could stay drunk and die
you know stay on cocaine and die or i
could choose the spiritual path
that i knew was going to not be easy
and i made that choice like i made that
split decision what was the wake up call
well i was doing a drug that takes you
down hard and fast i was doing cocaine
so i was taking heart down down hard and
fast you know i think a lot of people
that may just
um these days you know people are doing
even
more difficult drugs to get off of but
in my case it wasn't as hard to get off
of
because i uh for physically but also
because i had
such a desire to be better to feel
better i was such a strong desire to
feel better i got myself
i picked myself up off the floor nobody
intervened you know it was
my own spiritual intervention there was
no essential rock bottom
there was a rock bottom and a voice
within me once again like we've spoken
about saying get clean
and you will live a life beyond your
wildest dreams that's what i heard on
october 2nd 2005
i went to a recovery meeting that day
and i've been sober ever since
so we talked about like earlier we were
talking about like big signs right the
the story of your son coming and when he
came i mean
that is like giant signs um
but so many times they're way much more
subtle than that
and what do you have to do
like what are some steps you can take to
if somebody's listening to this and
they're like
i want to hear my soul i want to hear
the universe i want to hear
messages i want to see signs read the
book
i don't i don't i'll give you an exact
lesson that's what this whole book is
about this whole book is about
getting deeper into your connection and
awareness of a spiritual
foundation and a spiritual relationship
and and there's actually
practices in the book about asking for a
sign but anybody watching right now
could say
could say this simple prayer of thank
you universe or whatever you believe in
thank you angels thank you grandma
thank you god for revealing to me that i
am being guided
and ask for any sign that you feel is
resonant to you a song
that's something that's that's specific
enough that that you would know you know
yellow heels right
or you could ask for uh you know a
lizard or
a cardinal because you know something
specific
your sign will land in your face it will
be
very very quickly come through
do you think people are afraid to ask
for signs definitely
why because they're afraid to surrender
they're afraid to let over their
will they think that if i start to rely
on a power beyond
my own what will i be
it's a lot it's a big existential crisis
for people
mm-hmm um another thing they talk a lot
about is turning
um fear into faith what is your
religious background i was brought up is
there one jewish
um but i don't really practice judaism
other than the
cultural holiday things of my family
uh but my household we identify as
spiritual
right so we we practice the power of
positive thinking
we practice the practices of abraham of
course in miracles
but we don't have a specific religion in
my home
do you do you and your husband share the
same yeah
is he is he jewish is he's jewish too
again much like myself was not
really particular we grew up in very
reformed communities i was baptized but
he was bar mitzvahed but yeah
you know we live in a town where there
isn't a temple and we don't
we get a lot of the jewish culture
through my particularly my sister-in-law
who's become very
much she's like a sister to me she is my
sister
uh she's so divine and that she brings a
lot of the spiritual
uh sorry excuse me a lot of the
religious jewish religion and tradition
into our home
through the holidays so we have that we
have an anchor for that with my
husband's family and
my family what's your like what what do
you
how do you feel about religion in
general i think anything
that you feel brings you
a connection to the divine in whatever
form that comes for you
is perfect i don't care how people get
there
to get there through religion if you get
there through sports if you get there
through
meditation it doesn't matter how you get
there is it that you get there
how are you going to raise your son
with his beliefs and with his practices
like what are the what are the fir what
are the things you're implementing
already the most important thing is
respecting his feelings
so if he if he's
you know upset about something just not
saying she shouldn't be upset instead
saying i see
i understand i understand you're upset
right now or you know if he's upset
about something we can't do anything
about it in the moment like
he just sat down to eat and he's in his
chair and he's screaming in his chair
i would look at him and say i understand
i know nobody likes to be locked up in a
chair but there's good food coming you
know
just have a dialogue with him and just
say i understand and i respect that
you're not feeling comfortable right now
even if i can't change your
circumstances i understand that you're
uncomfortable right now
are there some things from your
childhood that you're like i'm gonna
i'm gonna change that and this is how
i'm gonna change it don't get me started
probably for all of us but maybe like a
couple of things you're like hey these
are the things like fundamentally that
are
core values for me that i'm going to get
right with my core values honoring his
feelings
full presence being fully present with
him
uh allowing you know one of the things
that my parents did do was
particularly my mom really taught me
that i could do anything
that i was capable of doing anything
there wasn't a lot of limitation
and so i'll carry that on for sure that
belief that i can do it
yeah do you have a relationship with
your parents
yeah yeah yeah do you think that it's
important
to are you can you heal from trauma
because again as we've said like there's
we all have childhood trauma can you
fully heal without
them being involved yes yeah
yep do you think they need to know
uh as any part of your feelings if
they're very involved in your life
and they're triggering you i think it
will only be inevitable if you're going
to do deep work
that that it will come out in some way
uh
because part of your work and your
recovery and trauma healing
is going to require you owning your
voice around what happened to you
what are what are some areas that you're
actively working on
i'm definitely still actively working on
full freedom like i just want to be free
from trauma i want to live to tell i'm
going to write a killer book about it
and i'm going to really really be able
to support and serve people when i can
fully stand in my
full freedom full freedom and recovery
and i want to really live that and i
know other people will say oh you never
really recover yeah i'm going to
i absolutely am going to my therapist
said i said i don't think you know 90
of people recover from this she said
99.9 don't recover from this
i was like okay well i'm going to so
that i can live to tell and help others
do it
okay so i'm that's what that's what i'm
working on
it's continuing to just shine the
crystal and go deeper and go deeper and
go deeper and go deeper and go deeper
with the bravery that i have to go
deeper
so that i can come out the other side
and really really help people
where did you get this kind of
determination too i came here
in this way you know i i think that my
soul as you said
just said like sign me up let's go big
let's let's experience whatever we got
to experience that we can genuinely
speak in this way
about what what you know to be true
and help shift shame help
people reframe their fears help people
become free do you believe that do you
believe in reincarnation
uh i'm not exactly sure like i think
that
i believe that uh we become spirit when
we leave the body
that i i know that i know that we that
that the spirit
continues on the reincarnation part i'm
not sure yet i'm not sure
i know this that spirit can carry on in
many forms
and guide and teach in that spirit form
potentially a spirit could take on the
energy of another being but i don't know
exactly
how i feel about that yet
sometimes i think we may i think we may
likely come back around yeah
yeah i feel like it helps define old
souls
right don't you think they're just yeah
wow
connections to people like there's
people in my life
then like we've been here before like
when my son was born
i looked at him and the first thing i
said when they put him in my arms was i
know you
i looked at him and i said i know you
so i guess my answer is yes i think we
can come back in different forms
do you think that we come back to learn
the lessons that we haven't learned yet
yeah yeah i think if we are going to
come back
we come back to to relearn and to get
closer to that connection to spirit and
i do
believe that if we get it in the
physical form that we don't necessarily
have to come back
so like
well i'm still sort of not still
developing my full belief systems on
reincarnation i do believe that
our our soul will continue to relearn
lessons so that we can get to a place of
being free
and in that place of freedom we may not
need to come back in the physical form
yeah
well that to me is where i root like
that drive
to to learn the lessons okay
to be brave is because it's like i don't
want to come back and do it again
yeah i don't want to have to do this
lesson over again because it's hell
right now
yeah and i don't want to have to do this
hell again
yeah and i want to heal as many karmic
life cycle wounds or traumas or
um you know just personality traits that
i don't want to do it again
i hear you want to come back bigger
better stronger yeah yeah
or i don't want to do it again tomorrow
how about that yeah
what's your uh definition of
or perspective on heaven and hell i
don't have a perspective on heaven and
hell
it's not a place i go to hmm
do you feel like you've been in hell
before i mean
you could use hell as a description of
where you know being in a dark
moment yeah um but from a
from an existential conversation i don't
know that that's language i would lean
on
so you just don't use those words like
no no never no
i would say fear and love right but
when we're in a state of fear we
are perpetually recreating
the stories that keep us i guess and you
know living in a hell
in a healthy state right feeling like
we're constantly in that trigger we're
constantly in that story or we're
constantly
in that panic or that pain or that
suffering
and i believe that it's when we we
reprogram unlearn that fear
and remember the love of who we are
that's when we can
live in this world but think with the
thoughts of heaven
right uh and
experience the world but have a
perspective that's
more aligned with
what you may call god or the universe or
love what would you say are your
are your top three biggest lessons that
you've learned in this life good
question
ah um the more me i become
the more confident i am
so my authenticity is what defines my
confidence
give me an example of um a time where
you said
this is one of those where i'm going to
be more me
i think i've been saying it consistently
for 15 years
just showing up every day saying okay
how could i do that more how could i
lean in more how could i be more me
how could i say the truth tell the truth
even more because whenever i notice
myself out of that truth that i feel
like a fraud i feel like
i feel like i'm unworthy i feel you know
that it's just i don't feel right
when i'm not in my truth that's a
feeling it's a feeling because that's
because that's another question is how
do you know who you really are
in this world of stimulation and
distraction
how did you find out when you have a
spiritual con foundation you have a
spiritual practice
you start to feel things in a different
way particularly when you're in your
contemplative practices like meditation
you can start to feel a energy take over
you
and you can feel a presence of joy that
you would never have known before and
you can
sit in that joy and that peace
that's who you are so that's why people
return back to a spiritual practice
because they just want to really
cultivate that presence of peace
and the more you rely on your spiritual
practice the more that presence becomes
second nature
big life lessons uh
oh the biggest one is is is
turn it over fully and completely and
i've had to learn that one when i say
turn it over to surrender
and i've had to learn that one over and
over and over and over and over and over
again
so much that even yesterday i'm in my
bathroom
on the floor on my knees saying
god take this from me help me with this
sort it out within 24 hours i was better
wow so when i really let it go that
things get fast
that things speed up the things work out
that's the biggest one
probably the biggest one um and then i
guess another life lesson
um i definitely learned the life lesson
to to
recognize that the more aligned with
service i am
the happier i am the more
the the more i can give in the world the
more me
i am the more connected i feel to other
people
that i can recognize myself and others
that is such a nice one i think you're
doing a great job being of service i
think your books are
are are a great example of um
of a big portion of that to share that
share that knowledge and experience and
be so vulnerable
and um connect with people in that way
because there's so many things that go
on in our life and we just overlook them
or we
um we dismiss them we push them down
and we don't want to talk about them and
we're embarrassed
but like we've been saying or some like
there's
we're all dealing with all of these yes
and
getting it out of you getting it out of
you and recognizing it
is such a big step and so your books are
are fantastic for how to do that and how
to recognize those things so
thank you so much thank you so much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button